Hi, my name is Andrea from Elegant Affairs,...
...and these are foods for Bastille Day.
To my right, I have French fries; in French they are called "pommes frites".
The perfect choice for Bastille Day.
But what makes them interesting is we put them in these little paper cones,...
...which you can easily make yourself by buying French-themed craft paper at the store.
Secondly, French onion soup.
Just take a little bit of French onion soup,...
...you can make your own or serve it from the can,...
...and make it interesting by putting them in these little white sake cups.
Then you can make grilled cheese in the oven, but not just ordinary grilled cheese:...
...a croque-monsieur, which is ham and Swiss and a little bit of mustard.
Cut them into bars and put them right on top of the sake cups.
They make a really fun Bastille Day treat.
And last but not least, we have French macaroons.
French macaroons are the perfect ending to a Bastille Day celebration.
I'm Andrea Correale from Elegant Affairs,...
...and these are fun food ideas for Bastille Day.